was by way another point do you are you
guys aware Christians you should know
this you've been following me the Bible
says that even in punishment in the
punishment to come not everyone will be
punished as severely some will be
punished worse than others you guys want
me to show you that that the Bible says
depending on how much you know and
depending
on how much you have failed to live up
to what you know and depending on the
sins you've commed your
punishment will be worse or less you
guys want me to show you that real
quickly by the way are you enjoying the
Q&A everyone else as you're learning
look at all the topics we're covering
it's not just defending the Trinity
we're learning about Holiness Purity
God's justice God's
wisdom God's perfect moral character and
and on and on right you want me show you
that okay let me show you that you're
amazing are you ready
body yes the more you receive the less
you obey the greater the Wrath and
judgment okay you ready
R ready you
ready ready okay R I don't care what I
say about you right okay I never turn
you Frank I may what I could on side but
I Love to You Frank okay okay ready
you're
amazing I you know I got a ADHD all
right here you go watch here guys watch
right here Matthew 10:15 truly I say to
you it will be more tolerable for the
land of Sodom and gomor in the day of
judgment than for that town now what's
he talking about he's sending them two
by two sending them two by two and I'll
go full screen to preach the
gospel among the LW sheep of Israel and
do Miracles and he says any town that
rejects you
and Christ swore on the day of judgment
Sodom and Gomorrah will have it easier
than them light switch go on so guys
catch
it Jesus saying the places and towns
that have seen Miracles or seeing Jesus
do Miracles their judgment is worse than
Sodom and
Gomorrah so on the day of judgment not
everyone will be punished as severely
here Matthew 11:22 24 then he began
watch here guys then he began right
here to reprimand the cities where most
of his mighty Works were done because
they did not repent watch what he says W
do
youin W do you bid for if the mighty
Works which were done in you had been
done entire and sidon they would have
repented long ago in sackcloth and Ashes
you see this this is actually
hyperbole hyperbole right meaning it's
not literal Jesus is not literally
saying he's not meaning it literally
he's not saying if I did the Miracles to
them they would literally have repented
because God is the kind of God if that
was the case he would have sent them
Jesus this is hyperbole saying you're so
wicked you make Ty and sidon look
righteous in comparison you understand
the point of Jesus
yes right but I say to you watch here it
will be more tolerable for dire and
siden on the day of judgment than you
for you guys seeing it the people who
have been given more Revelation who have
seen more miracles and not repent they
will be judged more harshly than other
cities and you capernum capernum you
Kern capernum
all right look what he says here who is
exalted toward heaven will be brought
down to 0es for the mighty Works which
have been done in you had been done in
Sodom it would have remained until this
day hyperbole saying you're so wicked
that in comparison to Sodom you make
Sodom look righteous and that
Sodom would believe and turn and be sa
hyperbole but I say to you that it shall
be more tolerable for the land of Sodom
on the day of judgment than for you so
are you seeing this here guys not
everyone will be punished to the same
degree or
severity all right you see that not
everyone will be punished to the same
degree or severity some will be punished
less others
more Luke 12: 4748 real quickly that
servant listen Brethren that servant
who knows his master's will but did not
prepare himself or do according to his
will shall be beaten with many stripes
you know God's will you don't know it
you'll be beaten with many stripes but
he who unknowingly commits acts worthy
of punishment the one who doesn't know
as much and does things worthy of
punishment but is not aware that he's
doing something punishable worthy of
punishment shall be beaten with few
Stripes why here's the key
here's the key for to whom much is
given of him much shall be
required and from him to whom much was
entrusted much will be asked so that
aan receive
much Lee yes see yeah was much given to
him yes so much he even saw the Miracles
now the Canaanites did they have as much
as aan had no were they given as much as
aan
no so why would you be shocked that God
would then give kites a chance to repent
but punish
aan and now I wouldn't question it now
it makes sense yeah two more I'll give
you then if anyone tells you all sin is
the same no that's not true not all sin
is the same because there's one sin God
will never forgive the blasphemy Holy
Spirit and not only that now watch here
John
1910-11 ple pilate said to him are you
not speaking to me Jesus why don't you
address me do you not know that I have
power to release you and power to
crucify you Jesus answered you would
have no power at all over me unless it
were given to you from above in other
words Christ is saying none of you could
rule none of you could Reign none of you
could do what you do if God hasn't
allowed and permit it because you're
nothing without God so he's reminding
him you would have no power and
authority to do anything if God didn't
allow it now watch what he says
therefore he who handed me over to you
meaning
Caiaphas has the greater sin so pilate
sinned but Caiaphas sinned worse because
Caiaphas the high priest knows the Old
Testament pilate doesn't so who is more
accountable priest
and whose judgment will be
worse the priest exactly why was
pilate not as accountable because he
didn't know any better and he didn't
know what Caiaphas knew so his sin was
less and Caiaphas was greater everyone
got this point final one I'm give you
see it
right final one guys let me know in the
comments section not distract because
this is for you these questions are for
you to learn your Bible and understand
your Bible and teach it now watch here
Matthew 5:19 to 20 final example talking
about Christians whoever therefore
breaks one of the least of these
Commandments did you guys catch it not
all commandments are equal some
Commandments are greater in
responsibility and in rewards are you
seeing this learn and meditate
understand don't just read our Lord
himself just said all of God's
Commandments are good holy and pure and
righteous but they're not all equal in
gravity or rewards some commands will
bring less Rewards or punishment other
commands will bring greater Rewards or
punishment because some commands are
more important than other commands are
you seeing it
here yes how do I know because if you
have the least Commandments that means
you have greater Commandments
right yes all right whoever therefore
breaks one of the least of these
Commandments and teaches others to do
likewise shall be called the least in
the Kingdom ofen you're going to have a
low rank but whoever does and teaches
them you teach even the least the
Commandments that are not as great in
reward or importance they're important
but not as animportant as others but you
still teach people to follow those least
Commandments that will make you great in
the Kingdom of Heaven for I say to you
that unless your righteous succeeds the
righteousness of scribes and Pharisees
you will no way enter the kingdom of
heaven so you got the point now yeah I
got the point now W you have another
question or you're
done I'm done I'm done you you answered
my question for